all right what's going on guys this is
Rob we will have a spoiler review for
Doctor Strange too don't worry but for
the moment I wanted to get this out
because this is a question that
everybody's asking FYI there will be
spoilers in this video so the question
that everybody's asking here is after we
saw the Illuminati does this mean we'll
see any of those characters in the
future of the MCU and a lot of people
are saying that we're not going to see
Professor X Patrick Stewart anymore
because obviously he died fighting Wanda
that's wrong I think we're gonna see him
again in fact I think we're going to see
all the members of the Illuminati again
like all those guys are going to come
back because here's the thing and this
this is this is why the small details
are so cool one black panther tells us
that and two America Chavez told us that
so here's the thing let's let's say
let's let's start with America Chavez
where let's start with her so when
America Chavez was sitting down and she
was eating pizza which by the way that's
a cool little Easter egg because America
Chavez always has to eat pizza after she
travels uh which is kind of cool to be
honest with you right like hey guys I
just travel from a different reality
take me to the best pizza joint you have
which if you're in Chicago it's called
pequods but the thing about this is that
when America Chavez was eating pizza
with Doctor Strange and Wong that
basically she revealed that every dream
that he has he's basically just seeing
an alternate reality version of himself
that his dreams aren't arbitrary right
every dream every nightmare is him just
seeing an alternate universe version of
himself so any dream he has where he
sees himself having a happy life with
Christine with Christine Palmer that's
an alternate universe out there
somewhere he doesn't dream the same
alternate reality over and over again
but he does see alternate universes
Wanda even said the same thing right
that like when she dreams she keeps
dreaming of all these different
universes where she has kids it's the on
running theme the only person that is
the exception to that rule is America
Chavez because there's only one of her
in the entirety of the Multiverse so
obviously that's the reason why she
lived because she's going to be a key to
accessing the Multiverse later on down
the line you can't just kill somebody
like that off she's going to come back
she's going to serve a useful purpose if
I'm being honest with you guys and I
really hope they're doing this she's
gonna end up on the ultimates I don't
know if that's gonna happen I don't know
if it's gonna she's gonna be like Al
Ewing's ultimates right like like in the
comics right where it's like her and
black panther and Carol Danvers and
Monica Rambo and blue Marvel Adam
Brashear my God I can't wait till he
gets him until he's in the MCU I feel
like she's gonna end up on that team I
don't know
um it may be because they're going in
the direction of the incursions and
we'll talk about that later uh in a
different video but she may end up on
the multiversal Avengers team right that
was led by Robert DeCosta of course
won't be led by him per se but back on
track right so the thing about this is
she says there's only one of her right
in every single Universe across the
Multiverse everybody's the same they
just all have different variants that
literally want to confirm that when she
was just dreaming of all of her
alternate cells now when Dr Strange and
America Chavez are tumbling through all
those different alternate realities and
they end up in the Illuminati universe
that's just a universe it's a singular
Universe out there it's not as though
it's a stand-in for the omniversal
development court or the Captain Britain
Corps or something like that for those
guys who don't know that is it's a
multiversal group the omniversal
development court is like the TVA from
Loki there's only one of it in the whole
Multiverse and it exists outside of
space and time technically it's called
Otherworld but uh but it's not like that
it's just an alternate reality where you
basically have like the Illuminati Reed
Richards and Monica Rambo and and
Captain Carter and all that kind of
stuff which as far as I can tell that's
not Captain Carter from the what if
that's just a captain Carter because it
looks like that version of Captain
Carter is from that reality right
instead of like Steve Rogers that's what
it looks like each member of the
Illuminati is from that native Universe
they literally talk about the whole
story of Stephen Strange from their
reality and the events with Thanos and
all that kind of stuff so everything
that they're they talk about out in the
at least the Illuminati does in their
universe is completely self-contained
they're not referencing anything in the
Multiverse outside of like incursions
and stuff like that and so that's our
first big thing because basically it's
America Chavez and Wanda and the MCU
telling us that version of read That's
How Reed Richards is in every Universe
right John Krasinski is Reed Richards in
every Universe across the Multiverse
they're going to bring him into the
Fantastic Four he's gonna play read
right like Patrick Stewart's Professor
Xavier the exact same thing now I
wouldn't be surprised because he's
pretty old and you could kind of tell
when he was in the movie like he came
rolling out in that wheelchair and oh my
God they played the X-men theme oh my
god dude let me tell you something man I
about fell out of my chair when they
played that song and I was like oh my
God yes X-Men the Animated Series oh my
God I was X-Men the Animated Series is
what got me into comics for those of you
guys who don't know it's the show that
initially introduced me to like the
world of Marvel and everything so it's
it's my over like it's it's the show
that started it all for me so it's it's
very sentimental to me it was just it
was great to see Xavier in the yellow
wheelchair that hovers and to hear the
X-Men the Animated Series music it was
just oh my God it almost brought me to
tears but nonetheless right like all
those characters that we see in the
Illuminati they're all going to appear
right they're all part of the Marvel of
the main Marvel Cinematic Universe
America Chavez told us that Wanda told
us that Stephen Strange told us that in
the MCU told us that that again every
time Stephen Strange dreams he sees an
alternate reality version of himself
Stephen Strange exists in every single
Universe from what America Chavez told
us apparently he's the sorcerer Supreme
in every universe but whatever the case
is right like things are a little bit
different now than they were before but
that means John Krasinski Reed Richards
is in the in the in the main MCU Earth
616 as they call it now which is kind of
interesting to know that the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is its own Multiverse
separate from Marvel Comics which maybe
it was always kind of that way I know
that technically the MCU did have a
numerical designation in the comics but
I don't know if that was actually
confirmed by Marvel or if it was just a
fan thing but regardless uh basically
like like Captain Carter exists in every
Universe all that kind of stuff now the
cool thing and what Captain Carter
really gives us is the idea that not
everyone is functionally the same which
is to say just because Peggy Carter
exists in one universe or in every
Universe does not mean she's Captain
Carter in every Universe case in point
the main Marvel Cinematic Universe Steve
Rogers was Captain America Peggy Carter
was just the chick he wanted to bang and
so because of that it's like okay I mean
that's that's cool there's a few things
that kind of that kind of change here
and there but basically it was like
Marvel like Sam Remy and all them
telling us like yeah man in the
Fantastic Four movie that's coming that
John Krasinski is going to direct he's
also going to be Reed Richards now the
other clue here is Black Panther and
that kind of tells us like okay like
this is this is pretty cool because we
know that like everything sort of got
thrown into disarray when Chadwick
Boseman passed on that he was supposed
to be like the new face of the MCU and
rightfully so right like Chadwick Bose
was just a he was a phenomenal actor but
of course with his passing now they
don't know who they're gonna have play
Black Panther they was supposed to be
Leticia Wright but then she popped off
with all her stuff so now apparently
they're going to replace her and maybe
they're going to have imbaku become the
New Black Panther but they don't know
and it's probably the reason for all the
reshoots that happened in Doctor Strange
2 because they presumably had Leticia
right pick to be the New Black Panther
and she was going to be on the
Illuminati in Doctor Strange too but
then everything went nuts and I guess
she got booted from the project I don't
really know and then in turn like now
they have no Black Panther and that's
why black panther is not on the
Illuminati because the MCU doesn't know
who the New Black Panther is going to be
and whoever the New Black Panther is
going to be is I don't know if they've
made their choice yet that person will
be the same black panther across the
Multiverse so it's not a decision made
lightly hence the reason why they left
that person out but this is cool man
because they basically just told us
who's gonna be in like the MCU from now
on and it's great right now the here's
here's the real caveat here's here's the
real question we'll talk about this you
know at a future point in time in the
movie when Reed confronts Wanda and and
if you're not a comic book fan you would
not know the significance of this and
people who are comic book fans just like
I know exactly what he's getting to
right now there is a point like the
point where like read oh my God it was
like one of the best as soon as I heard
that I was like oh my God right so so
Reed's like Reed's like talking to Wanda
and he's like I have two kids of my own
and I was like Franklin and then I just
I oh my God I totally began to freak out
that's the big thing that I think
everybody missed Franklin
[ __ ] Richard's son Franklin Richards
and dude let me
tell you something okay look here's Sun
Sun let me tell you something man let me
tell you something man Franklin Richards
to give you guys an indication right
Thanos with The Infinity Gauntlet is a
is a kid with a pop gun compared to
Franklin Richards man Franklin Richards
is a is an absolute monster right this
was a kid that can alter reality on a
universal scale there was one point
where like he couldn't control his
powers so Reed Richards put mental
blocks in place and basically Franklin
couldn't use his powers for a really
long time and then during uh Jonathan
Hickman's Fantastic Four run Franklin's
future self came to the past and
basically was teaching his younger self
how to use his powers so the son of Reed
Richards is sitting in his room under a
blanket creating a universe in the palm
of his hands it's nuts as soon as that
happened I was like oh my God Franklin's
powers are back like in the comics
Galactus was scared right like there's
one point where like Galactus snatches
up Reed and he goes to a world where
he's starting he starts to consume it
and he's like Reed we need to talk about
your son and reads like what about
Franklin and like Galactus is like
visibly worried and he's like Franklin's
powers are back and Reed's like
so like it's it's nuts man like Franklin
let me tell you something single
greatest moment in the history of
Franklin Richards single greatest moment
in history of Franklin oh my god dude
man Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four
right so like these celestials from an
alternate reality that Reed Richards had
basically got the attention of and
there's a whole bunch of stuff that goes
into it but regardless right like
Franklin Richards and his sister Valeria
are in the future waiting for this
perfect moment when they can come to the
present and basically save everything
right so like like you end up having
these celestials from an alternate
universe that invade the main Marvel
Universe Galactus shows up he's actually
summoned by Reed Galactus like fights
the celestials and gets killed right the
celestials kill Galactus so he's just
like dead and they're like oh my God
what are we gonna do well then like you
basically recall these words that
Valeria Richards had said to her mom
Susan when she had initially visited her
and then in literally Valeria was like
we can't tell you what myself and
Franklin are doing in the future because
if we do it could change the future it
could alter things and we need things to
say the way they are rest assured a Time
Is Gonna come Susan when the full power
that you have is going to be tested when
it's going to seem like there's no way
for you to win and when that happens
hold out hope and the day will be safe
so you get to that moment when the Mad
Celestial show up on Earth and start
attacking right and so literally like
like Reed has what was it uh what is it
Saul's Hammer I think or Saul's Anvil
like the the gun that can destroy
celestials that thing's basically gone
to Funk they shot it once and then Reed
couldn't get it to work again so Susan
storm has like her her whole Shield
there protecting all of them like this
is how powerful Susan storm and the
Fantastic Four is she's literally
holding off the power of celestials but
she can't do it for long so like she's
starting to give way then there's this
oh my God there's this light from the
sky and like they look up and it's like
what in the hell is that and Susan's
like it's everything Reed it's our kids
Franklin Richards from the future comes
to the Past basically he was teaching
his younger self how to like basically
use his power so he could absorb them
like literally at this moment in time so
Franklin Richards absorbs the powers of
his younger self and in like the most
epic moment ever oh my God the most epic
moment ever it's like Nathaniel Richards
right so basically before he became king
the Conqueror he's like talking to Reed
and literally he's just like he's like
here's something you need to understand
he was like in in every universe that
you're in you always meet up with the
Council of reads you always screw stuff
up you always end up dying or you
abandon your family or something like
that except for this one universe and he
says like in in every reality every
timeline that I've ever been to Galactus
has always had Heralds Franklin has only
ever had one Herald and literally
Franklin like takes this power of
Franklin like he takes the power of his
younger self and he's like rise and he
like he throws it and he's like to me my
Galactus and resurrects Galactus from
the dead and like they fight the
celestials man it was sun sun it's one
of the best moments ever dude it's like
like one of the best fights ever because
Franklin's got control of like the
control of like Galactus they're
fighting the celestials together
Franklin's like come come fail me and
like the celestials are trying to fight
back and there's nothing they can do and
and like literally they end up getting
destroyed and then they they just
weren't prepared and it was it was one
of the it was one of the best fight
scenes ever in the history of comics but
that's that's what we're talking about
man that's why I've been telling you
guys when it comes to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe you are not prepared
you don't understand you don't
understand right like Thanos with The
Infinity Gauntlet who gives us that guy
sucks like in terms of everything else
that's out there because now it's the
whole Multiverse right anything's a
possibility right anything's a
possibility son so we're talking about
the marquee of death the chaos king of
Matsu mikabashi like just all kinds of
stuff man all kinds of things I'm sorry
I'm so excited people but it is an
exciting time it's a very exciting time
to be a comic book fan right now yes
everybody missed that
[Laughter]
Franklin Richards
exists in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
now
that kid is broken as hell
yeah
to quote uh Doctor Strange in the
trailer from that scene that never
appeared in the movie
things are about to get out of hand
man it's gonna be nuts with that being
said guys thank you for watching uh I'm
sorry I went off on my little my little
tired my little ran I'm just I'm really
really excited right now I'm just so
excited phenomenal movie can't wait to
do the spoiler the spoiler review uh and
like all the little Easter eggs and all
that kind of stuff and I will catch you
all later
peace